minusgrade kälte und trotzdem warme
sonnenstrahlen auf der haut der winter
in seiner weißen pracht kann durchaus
idyllisch sein und wird doch allzu oft
unterschätzt
das behauptet jedenfalls sie für barbara
schäfer ist der winter die schönste
jahreszeit von allen über ihre liebe zu
eis und schnee hat die berliner autorin
ein buch geschrieben
was den winter aus hebt ist dass die
welt in so einen komplett anderen
zustand gerät also frühling und herbst
ist ja nur kälter und wärmere sommer
aber im winter gefriert wasser und
gefriert die landschaft und dadurch ist
es komplett anders
eine faszination die nicht jeder
nachvollziehen kann
gerade in metropolen wie berlin wo sich
die kalten monate meistens grau in grau
präsentieren
der winter macht schau dich und das gibt
man nur wenn man zusammen mit freunden
unter wechselt entstehe wäre noch schön
habe unglaublichen eindruck stimmt
gerade ist ein riesen großen bogen um
berlin herum muss gute laune haben dann
macht es frauen der graue himmel nicht
so viel um sich die kalte jahreszeit
angenehmer zu machen gibt es einige
möglichkeiten
warme getränke und kerzenlicht sorgen
für behaglichkeit und wenn es draußen
kalt und grau ist laden die eigenen vier
wände geradezu ein mit der familie mehr
zeit zu verbringen und es sich so
richtig gemütlich zu machen
[Musik]
auch einen wellness tag lässt den winter
kurzzeitig vergessen
man kann ihn natürlich von innen
genießen wenn man sich richtig schön
gemütlich macht zu hause wenn man jetzt
im winter im schneematsch draußen
fahrrad fährt ist es natürlich nicht so
prickelnd da hält sich dann meine winter
liebe auch in grenzen
wer doch lieber raus möchte entkommt der
städtischen winter tristes mit
zahlreichen aktivitäten in idyllischen
schneelandschaften wintersport in den
bergen oder die klare frische luft bei
einem ausflug im pferdeschlitten
genießen all das reicht barbara schäfer
nicht
sie reist im winter bis zum gefrorenen
baikalsee in sibirien hinterher und
sucht weltweit gegenden auf die sonst
nur wenige sehen und erleben
schneeschuhwandern durch einsame
landschaften in schweden oder mit einem
hundeschlitten durch die weißen ebenen
grönlands bleiben den winter und die
kälte genießt sie nicht zuletzt durch
den kontakt zu einheimischen die sich
mit den bedingungen vor ort arrangiert
haben
ich habe tatsächlich festgestellt je
weiter man in den norden kommt umso mehr
lieben die leute tatsächlich den winter
also da ist es nicht so dass man dann
schon im november denkt oh gott jetzt
wird wieder schrecklich sondern die
leute freuen sich tatsächlich stärker
auf den winter und sind eben auch bei
dunkelheit viel draußen sowie in der
norwegischen stadt tromsö sechs monate
im jahr liegt hier nördlich des
polarkreises schnee und auch wieder
legen die bewohner das klischee die
polarnacht in norwegens norden würde
depressiv machen
an der universität traum so der
nördlichsten hochschule der welt
forstjahr vita soll
er hat herausgefunden dass die menschen
hier auch ihre einstellung zum winter
zufrieden macht im norden norwegens
haben die menschen wege gefunden mit der
dunklen jahreszeit umzugehen
ruth aktivitäten auf diese sich im
winter freuen
und die sind für die dunkle jahreszeit
entschädigt die modernen china wurden in
norwegen erfunden und die
naturverbundenheit der einwohner von
kindesbeinen an
macht es ihnen außerdem leicht mit kälte
und schnee umzugehen
eine angewohnheit die man sich in
anderen kalten gegenden durchaus
abschauen kann also ab nach draußen und
den kreislauf in schwung bringen
der winter ist einfach teil der abfolge
im jahr
und wenn viele monate winter ist dann
organisiert man sich einfach sehr stark
damit und erfindet immer wieder
möglichkeiten damit umzugehen und es
fand sich halt selber auch insgesamt
faszinieren und wer dennoch keine liebe
für den winter empfinden kann dem bleibt
nur eins die vorfreude auf den frühling